aux etats unis à présent la justice
autorise le congrès à accéder à des
documents de donald trump sur la scène
du capitole malgré les tentatives de
l'ancien président on les gardait
secrets remy et parmi les documents la
liste des personnes que donald trump à
lui ou a pu appeler le jour de l'assaut
du capital la commission enquête
parlementaire se montre de plus en plus
pressantes sur le rôle de l'ancien
président voyez les explications à
washington de notre correspondante
thomas bonnin c'est un revers pour
donald trump dans le bras de fer qui
l'oppose à cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire malgré son opposition un
tribunal a validé le transfert par les
archives nationales de documents datant
de l'époque où donald trump était
président un transfert à destination à
des parlementaires qui forment cette
commission denquête l'ancien président
s'y était opposé en invoquant le
privilège exécutif qui est un dispositif
juridique aux états unis qui est protégé
qui rend confidentielles les
communications des présidents des états
unis mais ce motif n'a donc pas été
retenue par cette jeune j'écoutais la
cour soutient que l'intérêt du public
exige de répondre favorablement aux
voeux conjointe des branches législative
et exécutive
d'étudier les événements qui ont mené au
6 janvier les présidents ne sont pas des
rois et le plaignant n'est pas président
ce sont ainsi plus de 770 pages de
documents qui devraient être accessibles
pour les parlementaires de cette
commission denquête alors donald trump a
d'ores et déjà fait savoir qu'il allait
faire appel de cette décision et puis
cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire tente en fait depuis
plusieurs mois de trouver des éléments
pour prouver une quelconque implication
de donald trump dans les violences qui
ont été commises le 6 janvier au
capitole des faits qui ont toujours été
niés par l'intéressé lui-même alors en
plus de ces documents cette commission a
aussi lancé une nouvelle salve
d'assignations à comparaître pour des
proches de l'ancien président une salve
parmi lesquelles figurent notamment
l'ancien porte parole de la maison
blanche une décision une nouvelle fois
contesté par donald trump écouter la
commission enquête sur la manifestation
alors qu'elle devrait enquêter sur
l'élection frauduleuse qui a mené à
cette manifestation parmi les acides
figurent aussi steve banen lancé un
conseiller de trump il a refusé de se
rendre à une audition et des poursuites
ont donc été lancées par cette
commission d' enquête parlementaire on
sait que donald trump encourage ses
proches à ne pas à coopérer avec cette
commission denquête parce qu'il estime
que le seul but de ces parlementaires et
de maintenir dans le débat public les
événements du 6 janvier dernier à des
fins politiques parce que donald trump
estime que cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire et partisane